a rescue George he was 2 years old he's
not just a friend he's family
don't move a muscle are you crazy don't
move very funny you and I laughing at
your joke new guy he know about he cry
you can get up now and check your diaper
come on let's go your message about
Georgie ok George it's ok as in mirrors
he considerably bigger no he's
definitely bigger need to find someone
who knows exactly what the hell this
thing is
I found her no that's a lie technically
she found us what's happening to my
friend are you familiar with genetic
editing changes would be incredibly
unpredictable
increased strength towards speed agility
sales and save the cane run Where's
George I need to see him he is dangerous
for me to turn the man
we've created the next chapter in
natural selection project rampage works
got another one of your little science
experiments running around we made
of course the wolf lives
this time we throw everything we can at
these things and get people the hell out
of that city let's go save the world
that's a big arm don't know there are
other ways of dealing with people I do
know that yeah but that's not fun
George okay ready do this buddy
[Music]